au début de ce mois est ressortie sur
les écrans l'un des grands films
d'alfred hitchcock vertigo il s'inspire
d'un roman policier de boileau et
narcejac intitulé d'entre les morts
d'entre les morts qui auraient pu
fournir le titre à l'hallucinant
témoignage de jean dominique bauby le
scaphandre et le papillon qui paraît
chez robert laffont
car l'auteur est d'autant plus vivant
qu'il réside bel et bien au pays de la
mort j'ai un peu connu l'auteur de ce
livre rédacteur en chef de
l'hebdomadaire elle
il regardait le monde avec cette
gourmandise des tâches et des amateurs
d'excès un jour de décembre 1995
accident vasculaire coma quand il
revient à la conscience son corps il
bloqué de la tête aux pieds
seul l'oeil gauche peu cligner à l'aide
d'un code énonçant les lettres de
l'alphabet il dicte
en signant ce témoignage sans précédent
qu'on essaie d'imaginer ce qu'a pu être
pour jean dominique bauby le retour à
cette vie végétative et la prise de
conscience de son nouvel état j'étais
affreux avoir confesse-t-il avec humour
il lui a fallu se forger un nouveau
langage une nouvelle espérance
il se souvient des livres de l'enfance
de la musique de son père très âgés que
dans la semaine de son accident il est
venu raser un matin aucune résignation
dans ces lignes le sens de la vie
seulement